Outlook of the country he was given
short shrift I remember Dominic Raab
saying quite clearly your policies are
an electoral suicide note is how he
described it the members of the party
didn't believe them but goodness me how
that played out in the ensuing weeks and
I think the question as well is that Liz
truss booked together in terms of her
cabinet a band of Believers and the
question was really did she have an
other voices around that table that
counseled her for caution she didn't
take that Council and she got booted out
very quickly and you were talking
earlier as well about whether there'll
be any acknowledgment or regrets
responsibility taken an apology from Liz
trust because it is you know as she was
saying Beth quite astonishing you know
they had an eight distinct majority
that's now turned into a 36 point labor
lead in the polls the bank of England
stepping in to take emergency action to
stop and run on pensions after that
budget losing her Chancellor you telling
them watch it do you think that they
will be perhaps a glimmer of recognition
of what's happened in the last few
months or do you think that she will be
perhaps more likely to try and say what
she was trying to do
well I've actually just got a readout
here of what she said in cabinet today
so maybe that's includes some of the
things she might say I think she's
coming out uh she's probably coming out
in in a minute or so but in cabinet
today she talked about a short space of
time what her government had achieved
she might talk about the energy bill
again about the ni cart and she also
talked about she also thanked her team
her Deputy Prime Minister thanking the
team for delivering in a difficult time
she set out the priorities that she
still cares about high energy views
cutting taxes and putting in a plan for
patients for the NHS and she concluded
this by saying her time in the role had
been a huge privilege and her successor
will have the support as they now build
on the important steps already taken by
her cabinet to support the country so
perhaps from Liz truss a call from Unity
after she like Boris Johnson was take
out of number 10 as Boris Johnson said
when the herd moves it moves it does
it's astonishing as well just looking at
the you know cabinet readout that you've
just given us the second sentence saying
her saying that in the short term the
government had been in place they've
secured to some significant achievements
um the fact that she's the shortest
serving prime minister in Modern Times
And yet she's talking about the
significant achievements perhaps someone
who's trying to dig in and talk about I
guess trying to talk about the
Premiership as much as possible despite
the circumstances they find themselves
in well I think there are two
achievements that she would point to one
was the energy support plan which she
talked about in her resignation Street
and the second was cut in National
Insurance that was a rise introduced by
Rishi sunak to fund the Health Service
and social care it was deeply unpopular
with many conservative MPS because it
broke the manifesto pledges and they
didn't like it and and I think that hurt
Rishi sanak in the end and it benefited
Liz trust that she said she was
reversing it so she she has got two
things that she would point to of course
she's going to want to do that just as
Boris Johnson tried to point to his
successes and gloss over some of the
things that went wrong for him when he
was prime minister I think the question
is really as well is whether Rishi sunat
now begins to reverse anything she did
does he bring an eye rise back into
place or does he let that now lie it was
interesting yesterday that in his very
short speech outside in a conservative
Campaign Headquarters he talked about
sticking to the 2019 Manifesto because
something else that Liz trusted and
actually one of the things that undid
her that fracking vote was Liz Charles
he's trying to go on beyond the man
she's come out let's listen in
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
it has been a huge honor to be prime
minister of this great country
in particular to lead the nation in
mourning the death of her late Majesty
the queen after 70 years of service and
welcoming the accession of his majesty
King Charles III
in just a short period this government
has acted urgently and decisively on the
side of hard-working families and
businesses
we reversed the National Insurance
increase we helped millions of
households with their energy bills and
helped thousands of businesses avoid
bankruptcy
we are taking back our energy
Independence so we are never again
beholden to Global Market fluctuations
on malign foreign powers
from my time as prime minister I am more
convinced than ever that we need to be
bold and confront the challenges that we
face
as the Roman philosopher Seneca wrote
it's not because things are difficult
that we do not dare it's because we do
not dare that they are difficult
we simply cannot afford to be a
low-growth country where the government
takes up an increasing share of our
national wealth and where there are huge
divides between different parts of our
country
we need to take advantage of our brexit
freedoms to do things differently
this means delivering more freedom for
our own citizens and restoring power to
democratic institutions
it means lower taxes say people can keep
more of the money that they earn
and it means delivering growth that will
lead to more job security higher wages
and greater opportunities for our
children and grandchildren
democracies must be able to deliver for
their own people
we must be able to out-compete
autocratic regimes where power lies in
the hands of a few
and now more than ever we must support
Ukraine in their Brave fight against
Putin's aggression
Ukraine must prevail
and we must continue to strengthen our
nation's defenses
that's what I have been striving to
achieve and I wish Rishi sunak every
success for the good of our country
I want to thank you Francis Liberty my
family and friends and all the team at
number 10 for their love friendship and
support
I also want to thank my Protection Team
I look forward to spending more time in
my constituency and continuing to serve
Southwest Norfolk from the back benches
our country continues to battle through
a storm
but I believe in Britain
I believe in the British people
and I know that brighter days lie ahead
thank you
[Applause]
the short speech she now walks off the
waiting car with her husband followed by
her two daughters and really a speech
sticking to her message focusing on
growth focusing on low tax talking about
it is because we do not dare to do do
things that things are
difficult
[Applause]
so let's cross their leaving
[Applause]
um
Francis and Liberty had two teenage
daughters there with her husband Hugh
and she thanked her family and she
thanked her team in number 10 for all
the love and support and I think what
did we see from Liz trust there well
really it was a speech reiterating I
think what her agenda for government was
what her political philosophy was what
that agenda was that she wasn't able to
actually Implement I think there was a
little bit more of who Liz truss was as
a politician and wanted to be she spoke
about a Roman philosopher saying that
they wrote not because things are
difficult we do not dare it's because we
do not dare that they are difficult and
in a way that was the philosophy wasn't
it of her leadership I remember when Liz
transfers came into number 10 and I was
phoning around lots of her AIDS and
allies and politicians ahead of her
taking up the reins at number 10 they
said expect shock and all Liz truss is
going to come in she thinks the economy
is stagnating because of Treasury
Orthodoxy she's going to be radical
she's going to do things differently and
she's going to try and get that Target
of 2.5
growth and there she was really
reiterating that philosophy that you
have to take difficult decisions she
said lower taxes I want that to keep
people with more money and
uh some of her cabinet actually the
whole cabinet are now coming out a group
of them Jeremy Hunt there we expect him
to remain as Chancellor James heapey
just walking down the street Cami
badenock who we also think could be in
uh the cabinet just come out I think
later today Sophie we're going to get
more of the cabinet arrivals back in the
new cabinet for Sonic it'll be
interesting to see that as well won't it
Beth just reflecting on the Liz trust
speech you know she was really sticking
to her message wasn't seeing on growth
on Lower taxes uh saying that she acted
urgently and decisively I just wonder
people listening uh you know at a time
when we're seeing rocketing mortgage
bills she resigned after 45 days she was
forced to junk her entire budget do you
think that people might be surprised
that wasn't I guess more acknowledgment
of the extraordinary Premiership that
she's had rather than sticking to the
message that she's always maintained I
think there was an opportunity there for
Liz truss to do what she actually did on
the media on the Monday after Jeremy
Hunt jumped her into entire budget and
said I am sorry for the mistakes I made
you did not see that at the page and
there was no I am sorry if your life
penny more to come penny more
penny more than coming out and also
Wendy Morton there um the the former
Chief well she's actually still Chief
whip I don't imagine she'll remain uh
richardsonax Chief whip
um but anyway
um
yes just going back to what she said it
was very Boris johnsonesque in that way
but a different startle is trust but if
that doesn't surprise me really good I
was thinking about this last night and
really Rishi sunak is a return to more
Politics as Usual in terms of how a
prime minister might conduct themselves
if you think about Boris Johnson he was
a populist he had this popular appeal uh
he liked to break the rules uh he to his
critics showed Scamp regard for rules
and in the end that was his undoing Liz
truss was ideological really in her
pursuit of what she wanted to do and
quite a radical uh Rishi sunak is a
different type of politician so it
doesn't surprise me uh that Liz truss
was quite like Boris Johnson in uh sorry
in in talking about her wins and
glossing over her losses very much we'll
have more uh with Beth in a moment Liz
trust now traveling to the final
audience with a king who can bring in
our events commentator Aleister Bruce
and Alistair after the speech that we
just had in number 10 that she is all
the way quickly to go and see dick King
what is should she expects
the prime minister's coming in now to
the quadrangle at Buckingham Palace and
for a moment of punctuation
the political story pauses while the
Constitutional one takes
the center of that National stage inside
the quadrangle the car will draw up
outside the king's door which is on the
right of the palace as we look from
above and
when it comes to a halt the
footman will open the door and waiting
for the Prime Minister will be
the king's Aquarium
Lieutenant Colonel Johnny Thompson and
also the king's principal private
secretary
sir Clive Alderson
and it is in essence the end of her
period
as head of government
with her husband and the Chance
therefore after the formal audience
for Hugh O'Leary and
probably the two daughters to go in and
spend time with the King but
inside the palace now
once the welcome has been done
the Prime Minister will be taken to
where the king Waits
and after the king gives instruction
the Aquaria will take the prime minister
to the door it will be opened
and the aquarium will stand there as we
have seen on previous occasions
and say to the king
the Prime Minister your majesty and then
within the 1844 room which is
overlooking the garden at the back of
Buckingham Palace
it will be the duty of the Prime
Minister to inform the king formally
that she no longer has the support of
her party that she is no longer the
leader of the party and consequently she
can no longer continue
as his prime minister
she will then give advice based upon
what we all witnessed
that Rishi sunak is now the leader and
that she believes as prime minister he
would be the best person for the king to
call as the next prime minister and
first Lord of the treasury
now of course we know so much of this
but the Constitutional formality here at
Buckingham Palace
is a reminder
that the Monarch is the head of state
and prime ministers serve as head of
government not only at the king's
pleasure but at the pleasure of that
point of holding
the majority of opinion within the House
of Commons
the king is in essence the executive of
the nation but always on the advice of
the cabinet
and so once the formality has been done
and the burden of responsibility is over
the king will then call in
Hugh O'Leary and anybody else that the
former prime minister has invited to
come to and the King will receive them
and in due course Liz truss will leave
under her own in direction to whatever
plans she has but the formality of the
arrival of a prime minister here at
Buckingham Palace is now done and the
moment the king is content and the
process is done
the king will ask his principal private
secretary sick live Alderson to call
Rishi sunak to Buckingham Palace
and that process of course is all stood
by and ready but the function of it
again reminds us that while leaders of
the government come and go
the king holds the Deep Keel of the
national Constitution and that process
is taking place of course for the king
he is taking leave now of the service
of Queen Elizabeth II's last prime
minister of 13.
and of his first prime minister and it's
only a short period that the King has
had the benefit
of this truss as his principal advisor
they've held a few audiences
and for the king it was his
constitutional right to be informed to
advise and to warn and that process I'm
sure may have taken place it is only for
the future for us to find out what
gentle advice maybe was given by the
king during this process but for this
particular moment
for Liz Truss
currently meeting the king and
instructing his majesty that she can no
longer hold the position as his prime
minister offering resignation and also
giving the name of Rishi sunak to be the
next prime minister of the United
Kingdom
for the king to call as the second prime
minister and first Lord of the treasury
of his reign
so much Alistair we'll have more from
Alistair as the morning goes on Liz
trust meeting King Charles for the very
last time as prime minister he will
shortly have his audience with Rishi
sunac later on today we'll bring you all
of that and go back to Alistair Bruce as
well meanwhile here in Downing streets I
feel like her people perhaps still
digesting that speech from Liz truss the
Prime Minister who resigned up to just
45 days forced to junk her entire budget
and yet seemingly doubling down on her
economic plans saying that they can't
afford to be a low-growth country and
even calling for lower taxes let's bring
our political editor Beth Rigby back in
shall we and really in many ways Beth it
feels as she goes to meet King Charles
for the very last time
outgoing prime minister digging in at
saying not really acknowledging that she
got anything wrong despite the
circumstances
yeah look it was a speech that speech
was just over three minutes so again
very short I mean double the amount of
time that she uh spent talking about her
resignation
um but in it if I was to sum it up
um succinctly I would say it was a
reiteration of her own agenda and
political philosophy there was no regret
or apology for mistakes made that
brought about economic chaos for many uh
people that led to Rising mortgage deals
uh Rising inflation worries over Pension
funds forcing the bank of England to
step in with that 45 billion emergency
package in order to stabilize some
Pension funds there was no admission of
some of the mistakes she made instead
and this was quite johnsonian in terms
of both the style but also quoting a
Roman philosopher uh quoting him saying
I think it's Seneca saying it's not
because thing things are difficult that
we do not dare it's because we do not
dare that they are difficult and really
what is that summing up it's summing up
her belief that her policy strategy was
correct the execution was wrong and that
will be the legacy of Liz truss that
policy was wrong and it created turmoil
which basically kicked her out of number
10 and now she has left it to her
successor Rishi sunak to try to pick up
the pieces she wishes them every success
and it does feel like it he might need
it given the economic Outlook Beth thank
you very much for your analysis more
from Beth as the morning goes on now
we're joined by Sean worth uh we can go
to our next guest a former Danish Street
advisor former head of the conservative
policy unit now director of the
consultancy WPI strategy
um what did you make of that list trust
speech
foreign
for South Suffolk and I was rishi's PPS
uh when he was chances Checker
um and uh the main comment I wanted to
make was I think
you know it's incredibly difficult to
deliver a speech like that
um you know she she's had a very
difficult and challenging period as
prime minister a very short period
um but I think what she was saying is
these are my deeply held beliefs I
haven't changed them
um and implying that she still has you
know a future in public life which of
course she does she will remain a member
of parliament she's a proud East England
MP like me I represent representative in
Suffolk she's in Norfolk and I'm sure we
will hear much more from her in the
future but and it's to the future we now
look of course we now transitioning to
new prime minister Rishi sunak and I
think that you've underlined it the
crucial thing him for him is to bring
economic stability to ensure that there
is confidence in the country that we are
restoring the fundamentals of sound
economics
apologies for the wrong introduction
James cartilage of course the
conservation came to South at something
great to have you on the program uh this
morning I feel like it's one of those
days very busy here at Downing Street
for us and you're talking about the Liz
trust speech I just wonder how you think
your constituents might view that speech
you know this is the woman who
effectively crashed the economies you
had to junk her budget she's become the
shortest serving prime minister of
modern times and your constituents are
paying for it in the form of a higher
mortgage rates as well and yet she's
coming there to say that they adapt the
government acted urgently and decisively
that she was on the side of hard-working
people and reiterating the economic
strategy that goddess into the mess in
the first place I I would interpret it
as she's saying my beliefs haven't
changed now whether that means she's
saying the execution was wrong you know
I think the point is a speech like it's
very difficult you know she is at the
end of the day a human being who's had a
very difficult period ultimately um has
left after a short time in office and I
think as I said as I said that she is
saying look you know I still have a
future in public life and these are my
core beliefs but in terms of what I say
to my constituents and this is what
matters to me the businesses in my
constituency people with mortgages like
you were just talking about
um actually there's some good news which
is that there is there is a glimmer of
of of a sign that mortgage rates are
starting to stabilize if not even come
down some rates have come out today that
are low I was a mortgage broker before I
became an MP and it's really good to see
that of course the fact is interest
rates overall are still on an upward
path and that's true around the world
and I think that as I say the really
crucial thing now as Rishi Cena prepares
to become our constitutional prime
minister I'm going to see his majesty is
that we need to have a period of
stability and we need to have a period
where the public feel we're in control
of the economy as best we can and
preparing the ground for for getting
back to delivering our 29 Manifesto
which we were elected on
now you of course worked with uh Rishi
sunak when he was at the treasury you
backed him during the leadership
campaign what do you think we can expect
to see from him as prime minister
because there's going to be difficult
decisions ahead you know this is your
chance to level with people a tax is
going to go up and is spending going to
come down
totally and I think that phrase level
with people is so important one thing
you will see from Rishi is he will tell
it like it is he will be frank with the
British people about the challenges
ahead of us you know I I I'll never
forget I became his PPS just a few days
before lockdown
um and there was that day when he was
told you know the economy is literally
going to be shut down these large parts
of it
extraordinarily High pressured situation
had to act very fast to deliver furlough
and all these other schemes so he's he's
got that experience which I think has
been such a crucial factor in the
support he's received from the
Parliamentary party from all wings of
the Parliamentary party and I think the
other thing you'll see today is him
drawing on talents from across the party
um because he knows that you know in
these challenging times we have to be as
unified as possible but to your point
yes I think he will be absolutely clear
in leveling with the British public and
saying to him these are the difficult
choices we face I'm going to try and
carry you with me on that Journey
okay well we'll find out of course if he
does uh put together a Unity cabinet
later on at this afternoon uh James
cartlidge thank you very much for being
on the program today
we've all been watching of course uh
those live pictures from Bucky and
Palace where Liz trust is currently
meeting with the King we can bring in
our events commentator Alistair Bruce
Alistair
well it was the end of the period of Liz
trust as prime minister heading into
Buckingham Palace earlier on and
received by members of the royal
household and you do get that sense that
the state takes over in terms of the
Constitutional moment when the head of
state the king passes power from one
politician to another
and many people ask what would happen in
the interim if anything happened to the
United Kingdom and of course there will
always be cover because this is Cabinet
Government that the United Kingdom has
the prime minister is but one member of
the cabinet but the secrets in the name
the prime minister is the one who
answers to the Monarch and who therefore
takes from the Monarch the right to put
together what that executive is and it
will not be until a new prime minister
is in place that all those other cabinet
ministers are changed and again that
process is done through the king but at
Buckingham Palace at the moment I'm sure
that the moment of resignation has taken
place the naming of Rishi sunak formally
as the person that the former prime
minister suggests the king calls us the
next prime minister will have taken
place and it all gets much more relaxed
then and the King will press the buzzer
and in will come Lieutenant Colonel
Johnny Thompson the king's aquarie with
members of the party who came with Liz
truss and the King will have a chance to
just talk about everything and say thank
you and perhaps reflect upon quite what
a story they have both been through not
only for the nation but also for the
king losing his mother the queen and
becoming Sovereign and that first week
when as prime minister Liz truss
traveled all across the United Kingdom
with the King as he started his Reign
but it is much more relaxed at that
point
uh Alistair thank you very much we'll
have more from Alastair Bruce our Royal
events commentator as the morning goes
on Liz trust meeting Ken Charles for the
last time as prime minister and he of
course will shortly later on this
morning be seeing in the new prime
minister as well so we'll bring you all
of those events from Buckingham Palace
team
meanwhile back here in Downing Street
it's a very busy day on downings for
everyone listening of course to the Liz
trust speech but already it feels
doesn't it Beth I'm describes to Beth
would be here with us throughout as
though minds are turning towards what
comes next what we're hearing from Rishi
sunak later on today and how do you
expect him to hit the ground
well I think the first thing to say is
that many MPS are happy that this short
disastrous period under Liz truss is
over and they are Keen to turn the page
even those who did not back uh Rishi
sunak even those that battle is trust
knew towards the second half of just her
what seven weeks in office that the game
was up that it was going to be over it
was quite astonishing to see such a fast
Fall From Grace it will potentially go
down as the worst Premiership ever
people got to see the back of that but
goodness me she has made Rishi sunak's
job uh even harder now because the
economic storms that the country was
already facing triggered by the war in
Ukraine spiking Energy prices the way
that that was affecting energy bills
food builds Imports so rise in inflation
then compounded by Rising interest rates
around the world the era of cheap money
over these were all constraints on the
economy she then made a serious policy
errors really that exacerbated those
problems and now Rishi sanak has to put
it right I think there's a couple of
things to say about his Premiership and
what we might expect from him number one
yesterday when he spoke as conservative
party leader it was very much to the
party we have to unite or die that was
the message that this party which has
had seen such awful bloodletting I can't
remember anything like it I think you
might have to go back to maybe the major
years with the brexit wars and I wasn't
around I mean I was alive but I wasn't
covering I wasn't doing politics back
then I was I was still a student
actually
um but you know you you the sort of
blood letting has been so unpleasant and
the question is can he put the party
back together and that was the message
yesterday and we can get on to whether
he can or can't later but I think the
thing that I want to see today or I'm
expecting to see has got to talk to the
country they have got the worst polling
that they've seen uh for many many years
over a decade Liz truss was the most
unpopular prime minister ever polled
only one in ten britons by the end of it
had any confidence in her he's got a
massive credibility gap not just within
the party and and you know belief in the
conservative party that these guys can
get it together but also in the country
and so what's he going to say on the
steps there to try and speak to the
country and attempt and it is an attempt
I don't know if he will succeed but
attempt to re-set the agenda and try to
close the gap and re-earn the trust of
British people that have no out looked
at what's happened in number 10 in
recent weeks and what's happened to
their mortgages what's happened to
inflation what's happened to the economy
it's got to rebuild trust I mean
economic competence has been the the
Mantra on which conservative governments
have consistently outpelled labor and
won elections and now he has to prove to
the public that they still earn that
title it's going to be a tough message
as well isn't it do you think you know
it's interesting listening to the Russia
sunac supporter James cartlidge talking
before about how he was expecting to see
which is unite level with people and it
is going to be tough isn't it I guess
you know this is a man who as you say is
all about sort of economic competence
and how difficult do you think the
message is
so if he did level with people during
the leadership race and people didn't
want to hear it the members didn't much
like it I should also say though that in
the leadership race and this is what
some of his allies said to me afterwards
part of the barrier for Rishi sennak was
that because Boris Johnson was so
opposed to him and they calculated that
about 30 percent of the conservative
Grassroots were Boris backers it kind of
killed him off before the race even got
going he did manage to close the gap
actually with members over that summer
period but he did level with people he
said these are hard choices he said
there's not a Magic Money Tree he said
that Liz truss's policies were economic
fantasy he said that you can't cut taxes
at the moment when you have rise in
inflation because it's inflationary it
puts more money into the economy it
makes it more it makes the problem
bigger not smaller right so he did say
all of these things and I think that
that's what we're going to get more of
but what's the problem for him look if
you look at the public finances those
are funded tax cuts and the knock-on
effect for pushing up the cost of
government borrowing because the markets
were less confident about the
government's long-term fiscal plans has
added debt to the balance sheets of the
United United Kingdom government and it
could be that that fiscal black hole
that the new chancellor has now got is
even bigger than a few weeks ago well
it's not could it is it's even bigger
than when Liz truss took office and
there have been estimates from The
Institute of fiscal studies that that
black hole could be 60 billion pounds
now they reverse 32 billion pounds of
tax cuts so it's smaller but people have
also been saying to me around the
treasury actually the recent Market
turmoil and inflation is pushing it back
up so he's got really really difficult
tax and spend decisions to make we
expect that statement on October the
31st but what's he going to do about
operating safe benefits in line with
earnings or inflation does he drop Liz
trust his defense pledge how does Ben
Wallace feel about that does he cut
public spending as she said she would do
I mean one person familiar with the
treasury said to me the other day it
could be twice as bad in terms of cuts
that we saw in the austerity years under
George Osborne I don't know how it will
play out but I'm telling you that in
terms of just giving you a flavor of the
challenges that he has and that the
final thing I would say on that is he's
only been a politician for seven years I
think yeah came in in 2015 he's 42 years
old he is quite untested it doesn't mean
that he won't make a success of it but
he is quite untested and he has got the
hardest job of any post-war prime
minister really or certainly any prime
minister since in recent decades and
it's made all the harder by the mistakes
Liz trust made thank you very much for
your analysis Beth they're talking about
what to expect from Rishi sunak when he
comes out after his audience with the
King as the new prime minister here on
Downing Street I have to say we're
expecting him to give a rather different
speech to Liz Strauss where she was
calling for lower taxes and saying that
they focus on growth which you've seen
like a message from him likely to be
very contrasting indeed well we're
joined Now by Sean work who's a former
Downing Street advisor from a head of
the conservative policy unit now
director of the consultancy at WPI at
strategy thank you very much for being
with us at first should we reflect on
the outgoing prime minister Liz trance
what did you make of the speech that she
gave
Oh I thought it was okay I mean it I
think she just like embarrassing
situations and she's in the shortest uh
serving prime minister it's all a bit
embarrassing and uh she looked like
somebody who just wants to exit stages
as quickly as possible because the main
Act is coming on
um but yeah I mean I mean all eyes now
on wishes through neck
yeah all eyes obviously now kind of he's
got a really difficult challenge ahead
of
the head observatives absolutely
language in the polls a huge budget
black hole Public Services already
squeezed do you think he's got any
chance of turning things around
I do I mean everyone at the moment is
focusing on policy and quite rightly you
know we're in an economic crisis and all
of that
um his biggest priority right now though
is is just to get rid of the distraction
of the his internal enemies the right of
the conservative party that you know
every time the Tory party seems to be in
power happen when I Works in in the
government
um the right of the party destabilizes
it so he's got to somehow draw a cabinet
together that yes includes them but
doesn't let them let them dominate
things it's no um it's no uh coincidence
that none of them ever tend to appear in
cabinet in serious jobs or or feature in
election campaigns is because you know
broadly that wing of the party isn't
particularly well liked and
unfortunately there's a lot of them and
you've gotta you've got to manage them
that's your first pro to get rid of the
distraction then grip the crisis get
hold of that economic agenda and deliver
a budget that brings the market back to
confidence
it's interesting talking there about the
risks of the right the party interviewed
as deep Baker at the weekend who said
that if Rishi seen that kind of rode
back on the Northern Ireland protocol
that the ERG the right wing group of
brexiters in the party would improve
whoever was the new prime minister
um how important with all that in mind
do you think the reshuffle is later
it's massive you know Steve Baker
actually is is not one of the most uh
mad figures in the party he's not mad at
all but you know the sort of Chris
chokes and and I don't start naming
people you know who I mean
um you know these people are in in
really safe seats they never face
electoral pressure I I genuine I've
worked with them and I've Got Friends on
that Wing in the past so I'm not being
personal but I genuinely don't think
they understand the ordinary you know
what Ordinary People want to see from a
conservative party we've got a chance in
Michigan at least that we didn't have
with this trust in trying to broaden
appeal beyond the immediate membership
um but yeah I mean yeah he's got a huge
huge challenge to come the big big thing
is that those people don't become
distraction as he's trying to get a grip
on the economic crisis because remember
we're only two years away from the
general election and the big thing you
know the big message the Tories will be
telling people
um is you know remember they've been in
power for a long time so they'll be
saying essentially and I you know you
can quote me on this when it happens
they'll be saying don't risk change now
we're just getting back on track you
know we're steadying the ship there's
choppy Waters ahead stick with us we're
going to see it through and they'll try
and present change as I.E the labor
party coming in as risk and the more
that the the internal factions of the
toy party squabble amongst themselves
the the less compelling that will be
uh just very briefly
um
exaggeration or is it true
no they'll wipe they'll be wiped out if
they don't unite you know the big issue
that they've got is this economic crisis
but remember this winter we'll probably
have an NHS well we'll have an NHS
crisis there is still a housing crisis
there's a social care crisis there's
loads of crises we just don't talk about
them much because there's so much drama
going on at the top of politics but he's
he's going to get all of that landing on
his lap
um today you know so without a United
party trying to steer him through that
and as I say
present to the electorate that there's a
there's really choppy Waters coming and
he's inherited them he can't blame the
labor party because it's the tourists
that have been in power for 14 years it
will be by the time the election you it
you know he needs to have a a decent to
have a decent chance of just holding on
to you know a reasonable amount of a
party and losing an election he's going
to have a United party not not just for
winning it
but really interesting stuff at Sean
worth uh thank you very much for being
we can go back now to our disclosure uh
Beth Rigby and Beth it's interesting
hearing Sean work there talking about
the threat to Rishi suneck from within
his own party how divided they are and
the fact that they will face wiper the
election unless they Unite with all that
in mind how important is the reshuffle
shuffle if you like the football his uh
cabinet appointment is going to be later
yeah I mean there's a few things on that
the first thing to say in terms of the
divisions within the party
um he did manage to get by our scap our
Sky toll nearly 200 MPS now the
Parliamentary party's
357. so and just to come in very quickly
uh we can just look just to explain what
you're seeing on your screens it's a
removal van outside at Downing Street so
brutal as we were reflecting earlier uh
you can see there the removal van for
Liz trast as the former prime minister
or the outgoing prime minister leaves
and the new one comes in Beth you were
talking about how difficult it is for a
Rishi sunak to try and unite the party
but the word that he's done so far
yeah as I was saying um just in terms of
where was he with MPS he had nearly 200
MPS publicly back in him there was a
kind of sense of momentum yesterday that
this should be a coronation not a
contest but it should be said number one
that Boris Johnson did according to it
being independently verified by the 22
committee get enough nominations to go
on the ballot why didn't he well I was
told by one of his key allies on Sunday
night that he was told very clearly that
two-thirds of the party simply wouldn't
back him and in that position even if
you can get on the ballot the party's
ungovernable so he couldn't stand you
then had Penny Morden now I was told
yesterday that she got into the early
90s low 90s it slightly dropped back but
she was in touch and distance of getting
onto the ballot and she would have gone
for it and what does that tell you that
there was a sizable chunk of the
Parliamentary party that did not want
Rishi and even were prepared to go for
Penny Warden just to have a contest now
some of them would have said that's
because they want members to have a say
but others will be because they don't
like Rishi sunak and if you think about
what happened back in July and why Rishi
sunax run at the leadership was kind of
dead before it even began it was because
he was considered some MPS who are Arch
Johnson loyalists as the guy that
brought Boris Johnson down that's what
they think now other people have a
different view and say Boris Johnson
brought himself down with his own
mistakes and missteps but anyway you so
you have a chunk of the Parliamentary
party that's the question like yesterday
everyone kept a low profile and it was
all cheers outside of campaign
headquarters conservative Campaign
Headquarters but you've got to ask
yourself within that 100 people that
apparently wanted to back Boris Johnson
are there 35 to 40 that simply will not
support Rishi sunak and and if there are
he's going to find it really hard to get
any legislation through Parliament which
is why I go back to the point that he's
trying to stick to the 2019 Manifesto
there's two reasons for that one is then
it helps the conservatives to fight off
this call for general election because
he's executing the Mandate that voters
voted for and and then the second thing
is is that he's not going to try and
create wedges with the Parliamentary
party on issues that they might not like
so he's quite constrained in that way I
would say and given how constrained he
is and the fact that there are like you
say like a sizable chunk of MPS who
didn't back him and how do you think he
goes about forming a cabinet do you
think he'll end up bringing in people
back to Boris Johnson in fact Penny
Morden or do you think he'll be tempted
to do as less trusted to get his
lieutenants around him the people he can
trust the most well on the cabinet that
there was interest and advice from
people that other Butler's trust that
they tried I think to feed into number
10 over the summer which was that Liz
trust would be unwise to follow a
johnsonian approach to Cabinet
appointments which is basically push out
anyone that wasn't an arch loyalist and
surround yourself with your Believers
Boris Johnson did that in 2019.
and in a way he had the right to do that
because he'd won an 80-seat majority I
mean he really was at that point World
King if you like Liz truss also tried to
do it people were saying to me before if
she has any hope of trying to bring the
party with her she should build a
cabinet which reflects different wings
but I guess from her perspective her
agenda was so radical that she didn't
want to have a disagreement around the
cabinet table in the end that was a big
mistake because actually what happened
was there was no breaks there was no
caution there was no counter arguing to
some of the policies that brought her
down so that brings you to Rishi sunak I
don't think he has an option but to have
a Unity cabinet and what what am I
looking at uh well you saw on the right
of the party the likes of swella Braven
and Kami badenot they would have been
the people that maybe would have run
against him had the threshold for
nominations being lower are they both
endorsed him publicly will they be
rewarded with returns to cabinet into
his cabinet
you've got his key gang really I think I
think I've and as I understand it uh
Jeremy Hunt is meant to be stainless
Chancellor that's what I learned last
night I think that that will be the case
unless something changes today and that
makes sense because Richardson doesn't
want to unsettle the markets and Jeremy
Hunt has now become the voice of calm
hasn't he but then in the wider cabinet
well who are his gang if you like the
guys and girls that got him into number
10 you've got Mel stride the chair of
the treasury select committee you've got
Gavin Williamson the former Chief
Woodman education secretary Grant
Sharp's now Home Secretary a key Ally of
Richardson will he keep him at home
there's a talk that he might or will he
move Dominic Raab into home the four of
foreign secretary and Deputy Prime
Minister that stood behind him in July
and was summarily kicked out of cabinet
and went back to the back benches so I
expect that he will be back to
um who else who else I've got other
names Mark Harper another former Chief
whip there's a number of allies that
Rishi sanak will want to reward but I
also think that he will have to try to
keep different wings of the party in
cabinet but something someone else said
to me that's close to him and on his
team is that what he really needs to do
is bring the a game because
it shouldn't be at the moment given
what's going on in the country this is
their argument that you bring in people
for political reasons or loyalty reasons
which is what Boris Johnson is like
loyalty above everything else what you
need is competence because actually is
one of the guests was saying we keep
talking about the economy but the
problems of the country are so much
bigger than that look at the NHS record
waiting list it's you know people are
really unhappy because they can't get
doctor's appointments there's probably
like education you know school funding
how are they going to cope with Rising
inflation and funding day-to-day
spending on public services there's so
many issues strikes public sector pay I
mean there's so many issues defense the
war in Ukraine you know is there going
to be an escalation I mean they keep
popping into my head like the inbox is
horrific really yeah and so so he needs
he really does need to put in there an
A-game cabinet and I'm really interested
to see this is for me the kind of most
interesting thing now how much of a
reset is it and he really needs a reset
if he's got any hope of bringing this
divided party back together it really
will be more from Beth as it goes on we
have got Communications from uh Bucky
and Palace the right honorable Elizabeth
truss had an audience with King this
morning and tended her resignation as
prime minister which his majesty was
graciously pleased to accept that in
from Buckingham Palace
actually
good morning it is 11 o'clock Liz trust
has left number 10 just behind us as
prime minister for the last time and in
the last hour she made a short
resignation speech before heading to
Buckingham Palace to Tender her
resignation to King Charles well in a
few minutes time we're expecting to see
her successor Rishi sunak arriving at
the palace where he'll then be formally
invited to form a new Administration we
will bring you live coverage throughout
the rest of the morning
first though let's listen shall we again
to what Liz trust said in that final
speech as prime minister
it has been a huge honor to be prime
minister of this great country
in particular to lead the nation in
mourning the death of her late Majesty
the queen after 70 years of service and
welcoming the accession of his majesty
King Charles III
in just a short period this government
has acted urgently and decisively on the
side of hard-working families and
businesses
we reversed the National Insurance
increase we helped millions of
households with their energy bills and
helped thousands of businesses avoid
bankruptcy
we are taking back our energy
Independence so we are never again
beholden to Global Market fluctuations
or malign foreign powers
from my time as prime minister I am more
convinced than ever that we need to be
bold and confront the challenges that we
face
as the Roman philosopher Seneca wrote
it's not because things are difficult
that we do not dare it's because we do
not dare that they are difficult
we simply cannot afford to be a
low-growth country where the government
takes up an increasing share of our
national wealth
and where there are huge divides between
different parts of our country
we need to take advantage of our brexit
freedoms to do things differently
this means delivering more freedom for
our own citizens and restoring power to
democratic institutions
it means lower taxes so people can keep
more of the money that they earn
and it means delivering growth that will
lead to more job security higher wages
that is the live shots at you can see
there of richardsonac
uh which is like expected to leave down
in the street shortly
and to travel to Buckley and Palace
we can bring Beth Rigby in we are poised
on that shot to wait and see at the next
prime minister it really is kind of like
a roller coaster warning isn't it Liz
truss formerly attending her
registration to King Charles he's
accepted it currently there's no prime
minister
what was his Sonics about to become the
Prime Minister he's just about to have
his audience uh with the queen and for
him this really is I was writing about
it last night it feels like something
out of uh of the West Wing doesn't it
the drama the plot twists uh the
infighting I mean you couldn't make it
up in terms of uh art imitating life if
you like all life rather imitating art
this guy was basically down and out you
know he'd blown it if you like he tried
to run as prime minister people always
say you only really get one shot you
only get one chance to either win the
members over or you don't he was 40 he's
42 years old seven years in Parliament
and he must have thought
um at the end of August into September
well my political career is over what do
I do next and